black Founders giving drink program is
getting in the Valentine's Spirit by
partnering with the children's Heart
Foundation for the month of February and
here to tell us all about this
partnership from Founders coffee is
brown and nikora and from the children's
Heart Foundation we have Melissa
Cipriano thank you both so much for
being here thanks for having me Melissa
I'll start with you can you tell us a
little bit about the children's heart
foundation and what you do in the
community sure the children's Heart
Foundation is a non-profit that's been
around for 20 plus years and we help
families who have children diagnosed
with congenital heart disease and one
out of every 100 babies born in the
United States is born with some form of
A congenital heart defect which requires
invasive surgery long hospital stays so
it affects the family both financially
emotionally and what we do is we wrap
our arms around those families and we
provide services to help them get
through their Journey with their child
thank you for everything you do for
those families I'm sure they are so
appreciative of all the work in the
community and how great is it
different businesses tell us a little
bit about what you guys have going on
for the month of February so every month
we do a drink of the month and partner
with a new charity and February of
course for Valentine's we wanted to do
something that was pink and hearts and
loving and the children's Heart
Foundation for me is personally I
appreciate it my son was born with a
little tiny hole in his heart so it was
something that just fit so that's really
special and also special to have that
tie-in and just know how important the
work that they are doing really is for
the community so how does it work people
come in they order specific drink tell
us about it yep just order the drink of
the month a dollar from every drink will
go to the children's Heart Foundation
it's available at both of our locations
and it's a really good little latte red
velvet well I love it it's very festive
I'm going to top it off with some of
these cute little red sprinkle Hearts
while I go here and Melissa tell us a
little bit more about other things that
you have going on this year and just how
important it is to have the support of
the community absolutely you know with
the financial support that we give these
families we can't do it alone and we
rely on our community to help us
fundraise so we have our walk coming up
our partnership with Founders our walk's
April 22nd we've got other fundraisers
throughout the year and that helps
support many of our programs and one of
our biggest programs is our camp Menda
heart for it's a medically supervised
camp for heart patients ages 7 to 17 and
that's coming up in June so we can't do
it without the support of of our
community well we're happy to spread the
word about everything ladies thank you
so much thank you for everything you're
doing both of you in the community be
sure to stop by Founders and try one of
these delicious lattes they look so cute
JC I will send it over to you it looks
delicious